on the couch tonight a celebrity couple
yes who is
[Applause]
a flu backstage it's incredible it was
John and Emily not Discovery I'm married
and are you like brangelina or you know
Jennifer or well no our name is uh crunt
we've decided
I see how you got there I'm not sure why
yeah it just seemed seemed you know long
and long long-winded so crunt felt
efficient and sort of do you use crunt a
lot every restaurant
we sometimes send out Christmas cards
like Christmas with the crunts
that's gonna go wrong really that's why
I like it just living on the edge
because you weren't cool at all there
was none of that actually I don't know
your work you are a proper fan I was
full stalker status yeah I was just like
hey you want to go on a date with me
so tell people how many is this true how
many times have you seen Devil Wears
Prada I mean not 75 give or take 72.
no it's one of those things that back in
the day us elderly people used to
channel and
um no one does that anymore
like I said so cruel that was just one
of those movies that whatever whenever
you're going through the channels you
just stop and you I mean look has anyone
seen the film eh probably
[Applause]
um
there's a sort of Montage sequence where
Annie Hathaway's got numerous fabulous
outfits that they go through and John
one day I came home and he was watching
it and and he was watching the Montage
bit and he goes and that's my favorite
outfit
look at the beanie oh I couldn't get
Annie
I heard you talking somewhere isn't
there how your height difference makes
those stunts more complicated thank you
Graeme
Zendaya
that is a good story
there's there's a particular stunt there
I don't know if it's in this but there's
a you know he Spider-Man swings us on
top of a bridge and he places me there
and that's the bridge yeah that's the
bridge we eventually jump off of them
yeah
um so he's supposed to gently you know
rest MJ on the bridge and walk away from
her
it because of our height difference I
obviously if we're on the same like
points we were attached I would land
before him because my feet obviously hit
the ground before he does
so
what would happen well there's like it's
called a bottom Mark isn't it and the
bottom Mark is to basically it's a thing
that they do in stunts that is basically
designed to stop you shattering your
kneecaps oh yeah so Zendaya would land
and I'm the superhero I'm supposed to
look cool and she would land and then I
would sort of land like this and my feet
would swing from underneath me and then
she would catch me
but you're actually very very lovely
about you were like oh my gosh thank you
it's so nice to be caught for a change
Robert Downey Jr we should celebrate uh
this film because uh yourself and your
wife Susan team Downey this is this your
ninth film correct which is that's an
extraordinary oh yeah it is isn't it
yeah and what the working together is
that because I always think is everyone
else relaxed with the husband and wife
working together or I mean I suppose it
depends we met uh in Montreal sexy town
doing a movie and uh and then we're just
working together kind of ever since and
we like you know as conflict resolution
so we'll have like we'll we'll get our
Yaya's out on set you know she'll be
like oh God take the gum out take the
gum out of your mouth be a professional
and I'll be like Play that back for me
again let's see oh my God I nailed it
why are we shooting it again it should
be like because sometimes you do more
than one take
and uh and so we're I think we're
entertaining we we like if we uh if
we're gonna have little spats we'll have
them on set because then we like going
home Happy getting along that's you know
and then you're gonna do it again
because Emma knew you were the power
couple of Comedy uh in the early 80s it
is through the Cambridge Footlights uh
listen to the man listen to the man
you were the president of the Footlights
of Cambridge yeah and which position you
were vice president vice president she
was my advice
I couldn't give her up
I saw you come in first term we met we
were 19. it's so weird being 60 now and
on this side we've seen each other in
between we have obviously yeah
but I you I remember never forget you
coming into the Footlights Club room
there was a little sort of smoky Club
room where they did things called
smokers where people smoked and tried to
see someone trying to be funny at the
end of the book you couldn't because
there was too much smoke anyway Hugh
walked in in khaki entirely and khaki do
you recall that outfit and you stroded
it and then you had to do an audition um
you had to pretend to be the Emperor of
China
um trying to to get getting someone to
bring him a cup of tea and you sat in
your car key
on a chair like this
and just did this
you did the Emperor of China unable to
ask his staff for a cup of tea and I
turned my phone and said he's a star
sounds
sounds pretty groundbreaking
you were on Broadway but with your
husband uh yeah actually I should say
Daniel Craig's on a b sat right there
next week which is keeping it warm for
you yeah thank you yeah yeah I'm sure I
can forgive you actually Rachel because
you have come between me and Daniel
I've never met Daniel but
[Applause]
as I did he would be my husband
I'm gonna forgive you for that but um
I've got some bitterness do you know
what you can buy I've actually got one
one of those um those like screen visor
things that you put up at the top that
say Mrs Daniel Craig
you can buy them and you can I've got
one well wait a minute you drive a car
that says Mrs Daniel Craig keep it up
all the time
you know those sort of see-throughs
yeah I've got a good idea you have the
screen visor and I'll have Daniel
you have a lovely way of using social
media as a tribute to your partner Jane
yeah
I I just yeah I like you're in the bar
faces that you do oh you're in the bar
faces but then I also get pictures if
we're out or something I I sort of like
lag behind and get Jane by herself with
no and I take a picture of her and I
tweet Jane with all her friends
here's one YouTube of Jane Jane thought
she'd made a new friend but it was just
a shadow
the next one of this this is exactly
what you're describing Jane thinking
about making new friends
look at those crows
does she not know you're doing it
there's nothing where is he where is he
he sees the tweet
this this one is uh Jane is looking so
happy because her new friend hasn't
walked away yet
hahaha
men and then like you have it when
you're when she's posing for one of
these pictures does she go is this one
of those pictures where you're going to
make it look like I have no no no I'm so
convincing
there had to be there had been a few
words at home after you posted this one
just found this photo of Jane when she
was little
[Laughter]
there had to be a gift you must have
given her a gift after that yeah well
there you go
that's what being in a relationship for
30 years
I would have you both together on the
show you've been together 50 years
married 40 years but because of these
odd times is this the longest you've
ever actually spent together we've spent
this much time together a long time ago
but once he became famous no
how's it going actually pretty well
be adjusted to the new norm
and but then oddly all these years
you've only made one film together and
that was quite really that was 2004. two
two oh okay Losing Isaiah and Freedom
Lane okay was it Freedom land Natalia
that you didn't enjoy as much well you
know
he had become quite the person by then
and so it was his Camp versus where I
was so it wasn't as pleasant because he
was treated significantly better than
the blue collar worker
and but it didn't cross they didn't
cross each other and I thought that I
could have some input as I normally do
into what was occurring on that set and
then I was told uh what is your number
on the call sheet so I was like what do
you mean I'm Number Nine he said right
I'm number one so
cookie they're still together they're
still together it's all good it's all
good I said earlier you've been married
for 40 years but but all the I think I'm
right in saying uh you never proposed
Samuel
mixed up things I want to hear this
story go you've never proposed I don't
remember well I don't remember it
actually I I I do remember you
having some invitations in your hand and
saying this is when this is happening no
that's not what happened foreign
is very ill and he's going to die and
he's very concerned that we are not
married so we have to get married now uh
so that he can walk me down the aisle
that was his concern that I was the last
of his grandchildren
um not to be walked down the aisle in
marriage so so we have to get married so
now you have to ask him if you may marry
me and then you have to ask me will I
marry you and you did I did yes you did
okay okay
it doesn't matter
but the wedding itself
it was all romantic I got down on one
knee and did the whole thing no it was
semantical but you know we did you say
so magical I said romantic
you'll get through this problem
I needed that issue to deal with later
on today
is it true that one of the things that
attracted you to Aussie was that he
doesn't lie no it does it can't lie and
it's like we'd be at business meetings
and I would you know lie lie
just embellish things make them sound
better than they actually are and he'd
be why are you saying that and then I'd
be kicking him under the table stop
kicking me
what what's the matter with you I'm like
oh
but you've lied to him haven't you oh
loaves
yes yes yeah what was the thing about
you rode a motorbike oh God that was
when we were first together and I wanted
to be kind of like hip and happening and
I I told him that I had a Harley
Davidson and like I would ride it on a
Sunday down to Malibu you know boys and
dogs in Patagonia oh
[__]
I'm going to Patagonia rejected a couple
of months ago she got I thought she was
going to wrap around the tree with his
dog sled she wouldn't start to cut it on
if she's doing all her life I'll
Translate
thank you
[Applause]
I do know what you're talking about okay
yeah cause no because you were in
Adrenaline Junkies with Jack and you
went to Patagonia so you understand me
[Applause]
oh
God when I uh you know introduce the
character do you all know each other uh
but now Jimmy you and I bit Gooseberry
because this is I think the first time
we've ever had this that you guys you
dated at one point yeah yes yes
we didn't date we lived together
four years yeah we were a a serious item
for a while yeah but I remember Karen
Hines and myself we did this film
Excalibur together yeah 1980 the first
movie for all of us really it was it
really it was so it was so green and
ignorant about filmmaking but I remember
being out of the set this was Ardmore
Studios oh yeah Dublin and uh
how long had to break she was filming
but she was in costume and we were there
just visiting we hadn't started work yet
and uh the first idea the second ID said
would you like to meet Helen mirror and
said yeah I would love to so she walked
from like 100 yards away dressed and has
Morgana Le Faye
and Cairns my oldest friend and we both
were
[__]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah very good
foreign